foreign
intense sequence of events ahead of us
now starting tomorrow as you know we
will together attend the summit of the
Council of Europe
in Iceland then we will go to the G7
Summit in Hiroshima and finally we will
have the summit between the European
Union and the Republic of Korea in Seoul
and what we wanted to do today is to
give you some insight on the main
underlying themes that will accompany us
from one Summit to the next one
the first topic a big topic and
important topic is of course Ukraine
and here it is about our United response
to the Russian invasion of Ukraine
but it is also about our prolonged
reliable support for this Brave Nation
as you might know I was last week on
Tuesday in Kiev and it was impressive to
see and to experience firsthand again
the perseverance the resilience the
stamina of the Ukrainian people
and therefore I think we the supporting
countries also now need to show the same
level of stamina of perseverance
and I expect the leaders to Rally behind
this
I also expect the leaders to Rally
behind two my main principles
the one is that we will keep supporting
Ukraine for as long as it takes
and the second principle is nothing
about Ukraine without Ukraine
as long as it takes must translate
basically into stable financial support
of course also Beyond 2023
and accelerated Military Support focused
on the now and here
and nothing about Ukraine without
Ukraine means very strong support for
president zielinski's peace formula
we should never forget that Ukraine is
the country that was brutally invaded
and it's therefore the one that should
set out the core principles for just
peace
president zelenski himself
has presented this peace formula he
states that he is open to discuss
but the peace formula should be for all
of us the basis for all of our efforts
and the basis we start on working
then in the G7 we will also discuss
sanctions and we will of course take
stock of the existing sanctions and
future measures
as you know the commission has proposed
the 11th package of sanctions it is
focused mainly on enforcement and
anti-circumvention
and this of course is as always very
closely coordinated with the other G7
that are building also similar packages
we will discuss how to hold Russia
accountable
I will very strongly strongly support
the creation of a dedicated tribunal to
bring Russia's crime of aggression to
Triumph
we will also decide on setting up a
register of damage in The Hague
it will be a first step but a very good
step towards Russian compensation
so far for Ukraine
the second key topic of this sequence of
summits and meetings
is how to manage the relationship with
the changing China
while we all have our independent
relationships with China
I'm confident that the G7 leaders will
convene on a set of very core shared
principles
first of all we seek a multifaceted
approach to our economic relationship
with China
it is characterized by de-risking
not decoupling
at the same time we will seek to
cooperate with China on issues of global
concern like for example climate change
of course we are competing with China
this means we have to strengthen our own
economic vibrancy we have to do our
homework in our economies
we will reduce strategic dependencies we
have learned the lessons of the last
year
and we stand together as partners on
core foreign policy and security
challenges
that means
we will keep calling on China to refrain
from supporting Russia's War
we will reaffirm our unwavering
commitment to peace and stability in the
Taiwan Strait
we acknowledge the one China policy we
are collectively opposing any unilateral
change to the state of school
particularly if by force
and another topic we will protect a
narrow set of Advanced Technologies of
which we know that they will determine
Next Generation military advantage
and this brings me naturally to the
topic of Economic Security
it's a new topic it's an important topic
we've seen attempts of economic coercion
for example China towards Lithuania
we've seen similar practices vis-a-vis
Japan and Australia
we are most vulnerable to coercion in
general
where dependencies build up
and that's why we're taking action so
seriously to enhance our resilience
so to prevent vulnerabilities
we have for example to reduce our
dependencies on critical raw materials
we spoke about it a lot that is the
reason why we propose the critical raw
materials Act
and for example on Advanced Technologies
as you know we are currently reflecting
on upgrading our toolkit
for example an outbound investment
screening or Advanced export controls
Japan is already since long a front run
in this area that has therefore made
Economic Security a central theme of
their G7 presidency
and on all of this which I have just
discussed at the commissionable table
and economic security strategy in June
the last choice on the theme I want to
highlight relates to cleantech
decarbonization is the challenge of our
Century without any question we all need
and want to build
competitive cleantech industrial basis
that's of utmost importance if we want
to master the climate change
when we started the European green deal
that was back in December 2000 it was
all about rapid deployment of renewable
energies
now
it's all about access to technology
access to raw materials
and scaling up of manufacturing
and we all share these priorities this
is good
but the common goal must be the buildup
of clean tech capacities but not at East
each other's expense
otherwise it's gonna end up in a
zero-sum game
what the world desperately needs
is a huge leap in the deployment and
rollout and development of these
Technologies and this across the globe
the demand is colossal
so our incentives should be mutually
reinforcing not competing and the
opportunities are there without any
doubt and this will be a big topic also
to discuss at the G7
my final word is on infrastructure
strengthen our Economic Security and
diversifying all of this implies of
course also going beyond our Circles of
G20 or G7
it means reaching out to new con new
countries which new with new offers
of a partnership
and this is what as you know global
gateway is all about
now in Hiroshima I will quote-share with
President Biden and prime minister
kishida a side event
of the partnership for Global
infrastructure and investment in
abbreviation pgii
PGI integrates all the different
activities around this topic for example
also our global gateway this is the
flagship G7 initiative which we started
in lmau last year
the aim of this side event is to
mobilize the private sector
so we have invited leading cdos to
discuss with us the concrete proposals
and the way forward
they have to bring the private capital
capital we have to bring the de-risking
and the conducive investment environment
and that's what the site event will be
all about
so this is my Outlook on the next week
to come over to you thank you good
afternoon everyone and this indeed a
very important week for the EU for the
G7 members and for the international
cooperation in Reykjavik Hiroshima and
Seoul we will send a strong message of
European Unity to the world the EU is a
union of values it's a force for peace
stability and prosperity in the world
and we want to cooperate closely with
our International Partners to reinforce
our impact and to make the world a
favorite place
we all know the Strategic importance of
values for Europe
and the time stall for standard
Partnerships around those values the EU
and the Council of Europe are deeply
interconnected our EU member states are
all members of the Council of Europe and
we share the same DNA based on Democracy
human rights and full of flow so
together we must defend these values in
the face of growing inequalities and
authoritarian regimes and against those
who may think they can get away with
aggression with impunity and Russia
swore against Ukraine is the latest and
most blatant example those responsible
must be held accountable for violating
international law and the multilateral
rules-based order and we therefore
strongly support establishing the
register of damage which is the first
step towards an international mechanism
for the operation of damage loss or
injury in Ukraine and we will work even
more closely together at these testing
times the EU and the Council of Europe
to make our continent more stable more
prosperous and entered in Universal
values
we have also this very important G7
meeting and we are absolutely convinced
that we can make a real difference in
three areas the war in Ukraine
International cooperation and economic
resilience and security
we are closely following the situation
on the battlefield Ukraine is pushing
back the Russian Invaders but Fierce
fighting continues right now Ukraine
needs more military support and fast
this will be crucial to its
counteroffensive
Our member states are working hard to
supply Ukraine with more of what they
need we have stood by the people of
Ukraine since day one we solidarity and
resolve and EU citizens have step up to
showing extraordinary solidarity with
the millions fleeing the war and the G7
we will We affirm our support for
president zelensity's peace formula any
credible peace plan must be entered in
the principles of the U.N Charter and we
are extremely clear only Ukraine has to
decide when to consider potential
negotiations only Ukraine the EU and its
member states have also provided over 70
billion euros in overall assistance to
Ukraine and with the IMF leads the
support and with G7 contributions
discloses the funding gap for Ukraine in
2023 this is an important signal from
Partners who stand by Ukraine in its
hour of need
for over 14 months the EU has taken
action to weaken the Russian military
and our sanctions targets political
figures oligars businesses and other key
backers of this illegal War this has
never been done before it was not easy
it is not easy it took a lot of
dedication of the 27 leaders and we are
negotiating an 11th package it will
close loopholes and further prevent
Russia from a crying threshold supplies
meet these key Global players like
Australia Brazil India Indonesia South
Korea and Vietnam will also join us and
we will discuss openly and frankly about
why we are convinced these sanctions are
necessary and Justified Russian
propaganda is built on the lies and
conspiracy we are fighting back with the
facts and figures
developing and emerging countries have
expressed concerns that the G7 is
focusing too much on Ukraine and not
paying enough attention to their needs
and priorities
and we have heard their concerns we want
to build some Partnerships with
developing and emerging countries in
ways that are mutually beneficial the EU
and its member states are by far the
largest provider of global development
assistance last year 90 billion euros we
will continue to be a trusted and
reliable partner to reduce poverty and
to improve people's life
multiple Global crisis has strained the
funds of developing countries G20
countries must cooperate to find a
common solution to support low and
middle income countries in debt distress
multilateral development bench also play
an important role and that's why we
support the G20 presidencies work on the
reform of the multilateral development
bench together we need to build a double
system where power is distributed more
fairly we form of the United Nations and
the World Trade Organization and
inclusion of the African Union in the
G20 would be steps in the right
direction
curvitz and Russia's war against Ukraine
have shown how dependent and vulnerable
our economies are and we have already
taken action to reduce our dependencies
and address our vulnerabilities by
diversifying and strengthening our most
crucial Supply chains so we should build
strong and mutually beneficial
Partnerships with developing and
emerging countries we are also showing
up our Economic Security through
instruments such as export controls
foreign direct Investments training and
we have agreed our antique version
instrument will of course coordinate
with our GSN Partners on how best
response recursive actions by Third
countries on a test by case basis
after the G7 Summit will have the
occasion to be in the delivery Bridge of
South Korea one of the eu's most valued
partners and we have
and we uh where did we are determined to
address the ballot relationships with
them you know that in the field of the
green deal in the field of the digital
agenda we have concrete purchase and we
are determined to cooperate with them on
all those important questions
in the context of this European Summit
are with the Republic of Korea we will
also have an opportunity to address
certain Regional topics in particular
our ambition to be very uh active in the
indo-pacific area in order to support
the prosperity and stability in this
region and also to tackle the security
issues which are interlinked with this
as you can see we have a very uh
significant agenda it's all very clear
we're very United in the way in which we
tackle these topics with a view to
driving values such as peace prosperity
and stability these are the values
underpinning our project here in Europe
and we think in these turbulent Times
International cooperation is a key
instrument in order to bring a greater
stability and security thank you very
much thank you very much we will take
some questions yes yeah
24. I just want to ask you about the
Turkish election
uh I would like to take your opinion
your perspective about that election and
one of the president candidated
kamalo he said if we win in the election
we try to be the member of the European
Union thank you
so of course turkey is an important
partner for us I think the massive
turnout in these elections is really
good news it's good news because it's a
very clear sign that the Turkish people
are committed to exercising their
Democratic rights to go and vote and
that they value the Democratic
institution this is a big big win of
yesterday
now the elections are still open we have
to see for the second round We are
following very closely the announcements
on this file and we have to see what the
second round brings
president Michelle the same answer I
think this is very important indeed to
to commend the Turkish citizens uh the
electoral process is always an important
moment and we will follow what will be
the outcome what will be the the results
of this electoral process
yeah some
foreign
Plumbing from the Ft two questions on
sanctions ahead of the G7 please on the
question of sanctions evasion there are
concerns that hitting third countries
hard as part of a Crackdown on sanctions
of Asia and could end up driving them
diplomatically closer to Russia how do
you do you recognize that risk when it
comes to cracking down on sanctions of
Asian and how do you get the balance
right on this and on the same topic
China has warned of a strong reaction if
the EU sanctions its companies because
of concerns about products going to
Russia's military has there been any
dialogue with China about this topic and
again is the risk of retaliation here a
price worth paying thank you
okay
so um the sanctions are in the making if
I may say so they will they have been
discussed in Korea it's important to
have a look what we have in the package
as a proposal
there is first of all what you refle uh
refer to the anti-circumvention ban
um indeed we have seen that in some
certain countries there's a huge surge
of trade with European Goods
exponentially in the last months and
here we see that there is a discrepancy
between what starts in the European
Union
transits Russia and then ends up in the
third country
and therefore
um we are discussing as a deterrent
the question whether there should be
such a Transit ban there are several
watch points within the mechanism to
make sure that it is Justified
but this is being discussed at the
moment being with the member states
and
um then there is of course also the
extension of the transit ban
um what I just said physically through
Russia so it's working on Dual views at
the moment being on weapons and now on
Advanced Technologies aircraft
components and Jet fuels there's a
second element
this is uh you were referring also to
regarding third countries that buy
directly in the European Union and then
potentially deliver sanctioned Goods
to Russia here too the discussion is and
it's basically a warning that you're
serious about our sanction
that we could ban these goods from going
to that third country if there is clear
evidence that this is a circumvention of
10 of sanctions and uh delivery
deliveries to Russia
I think very very important to have a
clear strategy towards China and that's
why a few months ago it was last year we
had a strategy debate in the European
Council on on China that is debate we
saw conclusions but the intent to put
the topic to China on the agenda of the
European Council in June it has been
prepared and it has prepared at the
miserable Level under those species of
the high representatives and I feel that
from a political point of view the
member states are more and more
convergent based on three important
elements first it's very clear that you
will always stand up for our values and
Democratic principles very clear point
two very important to the risk a
relationships with China Economic
Security importance to rebalance our
economic relationship with China and I'm
observing not only on the EU side but
also in the United States for instance
I'm observing that the common rule is
the reasoning not data plink and 0.3
extremely important to address together
the global challenges climate change
hence these are the pillars these are
the elements on which I think we should
base our relationships with China we are
not naive we are Lucid it's important to
express a United common European
position on China it's important to work
closely with our International Friends
allies Partners we have the occasion the
G7 to address those topics but I'm
absolutely certain that the EU is an
important role to play to make sure that
our interests are properly defended
yes please
wait until it's red
Rebecca from carbon pulse uh so this
morning you said that a growth model
centered on fossil fuels is obsolete so
how will you persuade countries like
Japan that still rely heavily on fossil
fuels to phase them out quickly at the
summit thank you we know that our growth
model that is based on fossil fuels is
obsolete because it's destroying the
foundation of our existence it's the
basic
um basic reason the carbonized industry
why we have the effects of climate
change as we are seeing that right now
so the European green deal since the
very beginning focuses on a new growth
model and that is with a decarbonized
industry relying on sustainable energies
which are the renewable energies that's
what we're working on a circular economy
and on based on renewable energies with
Japan we have the very first green
Alliance
the European Union and Japan and this is
an overarching corporation on all these
different tracks that we're working on
also in the European Union to move
forward the principles of a green a
clean and healthy economy therefore it's
one of our most important Partners in
this project of course there are
different approaches in different
regions of the world but the aim must be
to have a climate neutral economy and to
to reach climate neutrality and to
decarbonize the economy and that's what
we're working on with Japan
yeah the EU is leader in terms of uh
green transition this is extremely clear
from for many years and we have decided
to to speed up our efforts but at the
same time because we believe in
international cooperation is also
important to engage with the rest of the
world in the G7 to G20 but also with the
global sales and on those topics and we
know that the transition is the most
difficult Topic in the at the EU level
sometimes also difficult debates related
to the transition and how we need to
take to take a measure in order to reach
this common goal which is which is
climate neutrality and that's why I
would like to insist is very important
to be in speaking terms with the global
South not only with Japan or the G7
members in order to talk with them and
to develop some common projects common
partnership in order to reach a common
role to take into account also the
different realities and starting parks
in different countries
uh thank you Vince Chadwick from devix a
question to president Michelle you spoke
about the need for over here you spoke
about the need for Unity and also
multilateral development Banks but when
the Ukraine investment platform was
launched last week there was a notable
absent player and that was the European
Investment Bank the EU Bank can you
explain why the eib is not a member of
that platform and whether that's a
mistake and to president Von delayan the
ebrd which is leading that platform
actually is having their annual meeting
this week and the commission's obviously
one of the biggest shareholders of the
ebrd
one of the questions the shareholders
will be considering is a potential
expansion into sub-Saharan Africa which
is an idea which has been around for I
think more than five years and it still
hasn't happened and the bank is still
pursuing it despite the clear needs in
Ukraine and isn't it time for eBid to
focus on its historic expertise and
background you know Back Garden which is
Ukraine rather than expand into
sub-Saharan Africa and if it is time to
expand in sub-Saharan Africa does the
commission support a capital increase
for eBid thank you
yeah the frustration of course I I'm not
able to to commend the participation or
the absence of the eib in a in a meeting
but I can assure you that I'm very
confident that the European Investment
Bank will play an important role for the
recreation of Ukraine and absolutely to
invent the member states uh which are
the shareholders of the European
Investment Bank will make very clear
that we count on the eib to to play a
very important role from a strategic
point of view this is uh this is a key
in my opinion for the ebrd
active in sub-sahara or in other parts
or the potential part of the world where
they they are supposed to be active I do
not intend to express a lot of uh
comments but I think indeed that in
these times in these difficult times
this is uh useful if the ebrd roots made
the choice to strengthen its efforts and
its investment in those parts in those
parts of the world in Ukraine but
probably also in some other countries in
the neighborhood
yeah I think also decision as well as
the ebrd is very active in Ukraine and
we're very grateful for that so they are
doing a great job but this does not mean
that they are excluding
um other
opportunities and therefore I think it's
an as well as
in
no sorry no no follow-up no sorry please
no thank you you asked the question the
answer is again Irene please you have
the floor thank you
no please
go ahead
thank you it's um on fruit crisis
because the food crisis is not over uh
now it's open uh European Union has
managed um to focus on food crisis in
2022 but the wars is not over we have to
face the food crisis in 2023 and 2024
what are the safety nets from the side
of European Union because European
citizens complain on the food prices and
on the other hand there is a letter from
13 member states that Express their
concern on Imports of agricultural
products from Ukraine thank you so we
should never forget how the food crisis
started and it is Russia's atrocious war
that started the food crisis we should
never forget that it is Russia that
bombarded the filled warehouses with
grain in Ukraine that Russia blocked the
corridor to the Black Sea which was the
main route to export the grain to the
world the
Ukraine was one of the main supplier of
the world with the grain and this has
been this crisis has been triggered by
the Russian war I think this is always
important to make that very clear now
since then we've been working
intensively to solve the problem for
example we have established the
solidarity Lanes
and 60 of the grain is going out via the
solidarity leans 40 thanks to the Black
Sea grain deal is going out again via
the Black Sea although Russia tries over
and over to block the corridor that is
um enabling Ukraine to transport the
grain to the Black Sea now what we have
to do is
um that we make sure that we do not have
a bottleneck he and the European Union
of the Ukrainian grain so that we have a
seamless Transit throughout the European
Union it's not trivial because you need
a lot of Transport capacity to make sure
that this grain that typically went
through the Black Sea now takes other
routes
um I think it's important that we keep
these roots up to the solidarity Lions
absolutely up and running
therefore we are now uh
establishing
a platform where we have all the
different stakeholders the five
Frontline countries of course the other
member states Ukraine and other players
to make sure that we have a seamless
processing of agri-food products from
Ukraine to the European Union but also
transiting the European Union and going
to other destinations in the world so
it's a lot of hard work but I think it
is successful work if you keep in mind
why this all started
yes
yes good I'm with China Media Group both
of the presidents just mentioned China
as we understand a special
representative of the Chinese
governments will start a five-day tour
including Ukraine Poland France Germany
and Russia starting from today for
political settlements on the crisis as I
understand his most senior official
Chinese official to visit Ukraine and
ever since February 2022 so what is your
comment on this new development thank
you
I think it is very
good that finally after after 14 months
president XI called president zielinski
before my trip to China I had spoken to
president zelenski and he had asked me
to raise this issue but I did and
president macron did too
it is very good that President XI spoke
to president zelenski because president
XI has without any doubt
influence on President Putin
and as a member of the security Council
of the United Nations China also has a
specific responsibility to do like
everybody else the utmost that Russia
stops the aggression
this is of utmost importance than my
second take very clearly is there is a
proposal on the table that is the peace
formula of president zelenski and this
is the basis on which we should be
working because Ukraine is the country
that has been invaded
and it is important that Ukraine we
deliver with Ukraine the proposals on
the peace Pro formula so that we can
discuss how to move on in this very
difficult topic China plays an important
role because of its influence on Russia
and this is needed
position yeah I would like to I would
like to to to to to confirm that uh in
our opinion it's very important to me
very clear that uh everyone with special
U.N Charter and it's why the peace
formula it's a fundamental basis for us
because the the basic principle is the
territorial Integrity the total
sovereignty and there is one thing
absolutely clear there is an aggressor
Russia and a victim uh Ukraine and
that's why you've decided to support
Ukraine as much as we can and we
sincerely hope that China will play a
positive role in order to convince
Russia to stop this aggression and to
expect you in Charter it's very easy to
end the rule if Russia would decide to
respect the territory Integrity of
Ukraine this can be immediately the end
of the war
Philippe
Phillips
returning to the green dealer more
European
subject the PPE was very hard
with
a certain number of nude texts which are
to be approved in the green deal the
president of the French Republic asked
for a a pause in this legislative
process so I'd like to know what's your
feeling about that is
to make very clear that president macron
from all the way through has been and is
a strong supporter of the European green
deal
and actually the parliament in of course
Epp 2 because we should not forget it
was in December 2019 that I presented
the European green deal at that point it
was just the vision
a political proposal in my guidelines
then all of us together
we've been able to cast climate goals in
law
we were the first region in the world to
do that and not many have followed sued
because to cast this in law means all 27
member states have committed to reach
our climate goals by 2030 and by 2050.
so this is the Outlook but much more
important is the detailed road map to
get there
this is what we call fit for 55. and
here too it's a huge legal package we're
basically done with it
and this would not have been possible
without the strong support of the
European Parliament without the strong
support of the European Council and all
those you mentioned are part of this
um the fit for 55
has in it one of the most powerful
instruments to fight climate change and
to cut emissions and this is the mission
trading system
we enlarged and strengthened the first
pillar on industry but we also enlarged
the mission trading system on other
sectors like buildings and Roads and we
put in place the social climate fund
I'm very brief now on an enormous amount
of different legal proposals that set
out the frame the legal frame for the
European green deal so I think this is
something really to be proud of but of
course we cannot be complacent because
the climate crisis
is moving on and we have to do more and
we have to be better now we still have
proposals in Parliament and I must not
only on the European green deal but also
on other topics
these are hundreds of proposals still
open so a lot of work ahead of us
so that we should have a look about what
the absorption capacity
is concerned
and this is something which we will do
in the next weeks or months but in
general if you focus now again not on
the general part of proposals in the
parliament but if you focus again on the
European green deal we have made an
amazing progress
my name is from Hungarian radio I would
like to ask connecting Ukraine what do
you think of leaked secret information
that Ukrainian president zelensky talked
about attacking friendship or pipeline
because it could destroy hungary's
industry
I have no knowledge of this I'm sorry no
excuse me but the new one denied the
information
yeah yeah sorry
that's the answer Tom
tomorrow
I'd like to return to Mr mccorm and his
idea for a pause does the art is the
answer that you think is Justified and
what about the one in one out principle
that is that you know you add something
then you take something because there's
a whole mountain of legislation
but the objectives are for example
harmonizing the internal Market
you've got 27
rules you remove them and you replace
them by a single rule which is a heck of
a burden a heck of a an easing of the
burden for industry now I repeat Mr
Macon supports the green deal and I'm
grateful for that because we need France
and France is doing everything he can to
support the green deal
now as to the bureaucracy for example
some of the reporting requirements and
there we've said that we'll
provide information in the European
green deal digitalization and resilience
will provide an information and
we'll reduce the requirement for
reporting by 25 and I think it's good
because it would enable us to ask the
members States
uh to uh it would enable the member
states to reduce their their reporting
so you know separate the green deal from
the bureaucracy there are different
things there
um I I think you you have to look at
what we've we've done in terms of
harmonization of reducing barriers in
the internal Market all that is hugely
significant and is very good for
industry but I'm quite convinced that on
the reporting requirements we can cut
back somewhat
no thanks for the floor I will
take you back to the Western Balkan in
our neighborhood there was tension
during the weekend between Greece and
Albania because of the arrest of a
candidate mayor ahead of the local
elections yesterday
um are you first of all aware of the
situation have you been informed by the
Greek government which is your reaction
to that and is this arrest consistent
because consistent with the rule of law
and the European values given the fact
that Albania is a candidate
country thank you okay
conference on the sequence of summits
that we are that the two presidents are
going to be attending please try to
focus your questions on the issues uh at
hand I don't know if anybody wants to
react okay
very briefly I have been in contact with
the president on this topic and the
permanent representation of Albania has
been following this situation as well
and in the meanwhile
the person in question did win the
elections with us yes we have been aware
of the fact and yes the candidate has
been released
thank you Ibrahim for RG the Italian
news agency
um president zielinski is asking to
start negotiations already in June do
you think it will be possible or you
have to wait at least at October and do
you have a consensus among member states
at the Council on speeding up this
process thank you very much
so there's a very clear road map on in
June we will have the oral presentation
this is an in-between report let's call
it this way the important report is the
written one that is due in October and I
think the council in December typically
deals then with uh this wide report not
only on Ukraine but also on other
potential candidates
and um
this is the very rigid and formal way of
procedure but how we move forward
within this these three steps depends a
lot on the progress of the country
and here if you focus on Ukraine that
was one of the reason why I was last
week Tuesday in Ukraine to discuss
in-depth the seven steps that are
accompanying the candidate status of
Ukraine
so lots of progress has been made but
still work has to be done therefore we
went through all the different steps
some steps have been already concluded
but some are still work in progress and
it depends on the candidate country how
fast and they proceed and how good the
quality is
um then to present to the member states
the option on how to move on
I would like to confirm that we are all
impressed by the progress made by
Ukraine but it is very clear that the
report that will be put on the table by
the commission after the summer in
October will be an important information
important uh document and then I will
put the topic on the agenda by the end
of the year and the member states which
have to decide taking into account the
progress mate and also taking you to
return the report proposed by the
commission
okay thank you very much this brings us
to the end of today's press conference
thank you for your attention